et bien vous allez le constater le
château a par exemple augmenté son
nombre d'entrées de 33% hervé qui rien
gilles et rochers à l'ouverture des
lieux ce matin là ils sont une grosse
dizaine à monter à l'assaut de la
forteresse
on ne le dirait pas mais ça fait un
tiers de visiteurs en plus par rapport à
l'an dernier
la billetterie est là pour en témoigner
après le passage de lièvre le châtel à
la télé il s'est vendu en juillet 33 %
d'entrées en plus à la forteresse qu'en
juillet 2017
tous les habitués de la commune le
confirme l'émission de france 2 a boosté
la fréquentation et d'un impact
touristique intéressant et je dirais
même intéressant sur le point le point
de vue local parce que des habitants qui
sont de la région pithiviers par exemple
ont découvert hébreu le châtel en
regardant l'émission
il ne savait pas qu'il y avait un
village médiéval dans le loiret c'est
quand même surprenant et donc on a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de listes
locales en plus bien sûr de l'impact
qu'a eu sur les touristes qui sont dans
le coin qui disent venir on va pousser
jusqu'à livre le châtel dans le seul
commerce de bouche du village même son
cloche
le chiffre d'affaires de cet été des
cols on l'a ressentie surtout mois de
juillet et un bruit une vingtaine de
pourcents on va dire entre le matin
l'après midi le restaurant les balades
des gens qui se promènent qui
connaissait pas viable chatel et qui ont
découvert par rapport à l'émission de la
télé oui c'est formidable
classé dans le palmarès des plus beaux
villages de france hier le châtel voit
déambuler dans ces ruelles cent mille
visiteurs à l'année en moyenne un
chiffre qui sera certainement dépassé en